hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the battle royale genre has become a
huge business and everyone is jumping on
the bandwagon minecraft Hunger Games
ARMA 2 and rust popularized as far back
as 2012 pub G and fortnight ruled the
world at the moment but I found more
than 30 titles which want to grab top
spot in the battle royale table
don't worry though I've narrowed it down
to 12 which I think could take you away
from your current favorite and by the
way eight of these titles are going to
be completely free to place
let's start with realm royale which is
making huge waves over on the PC what
makes this one slightly different from
what night is the class system it's more
like if overwatch and fortnight had an
illegitimate child realm royale is still
100 people dropping from the sky and
fighting in an ever-shrinking circle but
the inclusion of character abilities
changes up encounters as the five main
classes of mage engineer hunter assassin
and warrior will require slightly
different tactics to overcome on top of
that there's a crafting system there are
even mount to travel faster across the
map and I'm sure there'll be skins to
purchase to ride on top of a giraffe or
the loss of Raptor hopefully anyway and
the best part of all who needs a glider
when you can land like a super hero
as I'm writing this realm royale is in
closed beta on the ps4 so as soon as
it's released
I'll throw together a beginner's guide
[Music]
here's one I've been dying to talk about
for ages dying light is trying its hand
at battle royale and it's going to be
completely free now all the official
reveals are out of the way I can tell
you a few more details about dying light
bad Bloods this is set in first person
and involves huge amounts of parkour
elements in a city filled with AI
zombies instead of 100 players fighting
to the death dying light bad blood pits
12 people against each other who must
escape before nightfall we can kill
everyone we see but the objective is to
find samples in the world the person who
gets the right amount gets the last seat
on the escaped chopper will you collect
enough on your own or will you wait to
take the samples from other players
dying light will begin on PC as a
founders purchase but will come to all
formats completely for free what do you
think two first-person parkour in Battle
Royale I'll admit it I am super
intrigued by this one Battle Royale has
had such an impact on gamers that even
call of duty black ops 4 is releasing a
version of VR this is Call of Duty
battle royale
this is blackout mode it will completely
focus on what Call of Duty is renowned
for the shooting mechanics and controls
the stylized cinematic look and best of
all there will be 10 years of history on
a single map with references to modern
warfare 2 ghosts and of course the black
ops series and it gets even better as
vehicles have been confirmed we'll get
our first chance to play during the ps4
beta on September the 10th and if I get
myself a key I'll upload my thoughts
very soon
quickly I'd like to include h1z1 I know
it's been here since the beginning but
it's now fully released on ps4 and
offers the same stale battle pass as
fought night at a lower price if you
prefer more boots on the ground and a
little more gritty realism
I recommend jumping back into h1z1
do you know how hard it is to say h1z1
instead of h1z1 bloody ridiculously hard
moving on have you heard of SOS it's
currently free to play on PC but the
devs have outlined their desire to bring
SOS to consoles ASAP the premise is a
little different to fortnight as 32
players our contestants rather start on
lacunae Island and search for relics
another twist involves viewers making
decisions to affect the island of their
favorite streamer but in my eyes the
best thing of all is the proximity chat
which allows fellow contestants to talk
to one another
adding the possibility of being tricked
and literally backstabbed the game is
having huge issues at the moment trying
to realize if it's a fully fledged
battle royale title or if it wants to
keep the original content of the game
which was about betrayal and those
relics we mentioned just like dying
lights the island is filled with
creatures that can infect and brutalize
you so an allegiance however fragile may
be the best course of action back in
2012 minecraft was modded to include a
hunger games mode which is arguably the
birth of the battle royale genre the
irony here is that the hunger games the
book series and the movies directly
ripoff ideas from battle royale which is
a brilliant film in its own right I
demand you go watch it now if you
haven't already before I get to side
tracks let's go back to the point that
minecraft Hunger Games was so
inspirational that six years later we
have survival games battle royale as
always the premise is to fight and
survive but the world is dynamically
created causing everyone to be in the
same position of not knowing the map
straight away essentially this prevents
new players from being outsmarted by the
terrain at present the project is in
early access on Steam and support up to
64 players another game with a similar
approach to graphical fidelity is reck
Royale a free-to-play virtual reality
take on battle royale this is much
smaller than 100 players in fact it's
only 16 but you'd be surprised how scary
it is to know someone could be behind
you at any moment
ready to hit you over the head with a
fright
[Music]
let's look at horizon sauce it's another
steam title with huge ambitions yet
again it's free-to-play and start with
100 players dropping towards an
abandoned Island horizon sauce just like
realm royale has distinctive heroes with
unique weapons and skills to utilize
there's the typical scavenging element
but even for tonight's building feature
makes it over to horizon sauce allowing
fortresses and obstacles to be erected
so if other games were a mix of
overwatch and fortnight this one would
be a mix of fortnight and realm royale
it's quite interesting how they put it
all together
so definitely give it a look we can take
this one step further though with a
mobile game you may want to consider
this is for craft as the name suggests
this is almost the exact same game as
fortnight the devs made this title
available to Android players before
fortnight were able to move across to
Android whether it's still thriving when
fortnight completely takes over the
Android phone and tablet scene is yet to
be known but for a less polished version
of fortnight mobile this is the game for
you I can't see this staying around for
very long because it's so identical it's
frightening epic games will probably sue
them into closure very soon
[Music]
oh he's a good one imagine Battle Royale
and Mad Max mixed together some pretty
damn good doesn't it fractured lands is
attempting to do this but at present
it's in such an early state of
development the game is so far from
completion
what stands out to me is the
post-apocalyptic visuals and the armored
cars you travel in the cows themselves
are starting point and they can be
upgraded such as thrusters to make you
go quicker or even vertical thrusters to
bunnyhop over obstacles the item
management here resembles pub G and so
does the gameplay fractured land stands
out from the other competitors in the
battle royale scene so let's cross our
fingers and hope that they develop this
into a top tier battle royale title
[Music]
engagement and prepare a full battle
royale match transport
one next we have islands of nine Battle
Royale
most aspects are identical to your
favorite they are games with a few
tweaks such as the toxic gas area being
replaced with a plasma field and the
instead of the abandoned island being on
earth
it's instead on an alien planet the
visuals here look freaking gorgeous
which should attract players that find
fortnight's art style and a little too
childlike work has finally begun on a
console version of islands of nine but
it's accessible right now on Steam for
you PC players
welcome to the dome there
and finally a game with a huge amount of
potential is the Darwin project again
this one will take time to come to
console from what we've seen of the pc
version the darwin project is far more
unique than any of the other titles on
the list with an impending Ice Age about
to rock the world it's time for survival
of the fittest hence the name Darwin in
the title not only will you be facing
other players in the Darwin project
you'll be fighting the wilderness and
the enclosing whether something as
simple as lighting a fire for heat will
allow others to track your position and
tracking is a pivotal part of the game
looking for footprints are any of the
tell-tale signs that someone has been
here before you allow us to pursue
players but we're always leaving our own
trail behind us
for other players to follow it perfectly
pushes survival and the battle between
predator and prey
at present the Darwin project is free to
play on Steam and judging by the
branding lately this looks to be picked
up by Microsoft so we may not see it on
ps4 at first I'll let you know when I
find out more information so there we
have it a dozen battle royale games that
want your attention or do you think
we'll anything pull you away from
fortnight's oh and keep in mind eight of
these games will be free-to-play so
there's no reason to ignore them give
them a download and see what you think
they'll be dropping as soon as this
month up to about a year away so there's
something new to play almost every
single month in the Battle Royale genre
anyway I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a bloody pleasure like always
I'll see you next time
[Music]